the
meeting is now being live streamed
so right then
um right the purpose of today's meeting
is to consider the application for a
temporary events notice
made by eternity events essex in respect
to the premises of 43 tuning away
rayleigh
please could the applicant
or representative introduce themselves
hello
so um i'm the applicant um anita
robertson
um so i assist in running um
eternity events with my husband
which we've done for the past 21 years
our business has grown over the years to
incorporate the sale of alcohol
that's all we need just to introduce
yourself at the moment
a little bit later thank you
um
and do you have any witnesses you wish
to call
um
tony is here and um patricia and alex
neville whose party is um
brilliant thank you
right
please could the council's licensing
officer introduce themselves
good afternoon i'm steve greener i am
the principal licensing officer for
rocha district council
and stephen do you have any witnesses
you might wish to call no i do not thank
you thank you and could the responsible
authority introduce themselves
afternoon my name is von sheridan
rochford district council environmental
health
and
have you got any witnesses you might
want to call later no
no
all right
have all the parties received the agenda
and report for today's hearing
yes by taking nodding heads
brilliant
right the committee will now follow the
seizures set out in procedural notes on
three four rights
now this is to consider the report of
the assistant director people
communities which asked me to determine
application
for the issue of a temporary events
notice made under section 100 of the
licensing act 2003 in respect to the
premises known as 43 to england way
bailey
there we go
and
right
right cool all parties be reminded they
have 15 minutes to present their cases
and could mr greener like to summarize
the application please
thank you very much as i said um we will
literally just do a summary rather than
me from reading out the full application
as it's already been said
this is an application for a temporary
event notice under section 100 of the
licensing act
on the 11th of november 2021 a temporary
event notice was received by email from
anita robertson of eternity events limit
events essex
and a copy of the application is
attached as appendix a
the notice is for a 21st birthday event
to be held at tillingham way in rayleigh
on the 4th of december 2021 between 1800
hours and midnight on the 4th of
december 2021.
the licensible activities are for the
sale of alcohol and the provision of
regulate entertainment with a maximum
number of people attending the event is
to be 100. the venue does not hold a
premises license and no conditions can
be applied to this application
the application was sent to essex police
and environmental health as i said on
the 11th of november for consultation
with a deadline of the 16th of november
2021.
the application was reviewed by essex
police licensing team and no
representations have been made against
the application
an objection notice has been received
from rocha district council
environmental health team on the grounds
that the use of the premises in
accordance with the temporary events
notice would undermine the
public nuisance objective of the act
and a copy of the objection notice is
attached as appendix b
with permission i'm going to jump to the
very end of the report is around the
recommendations it is proposed that the
subcommittee resolves
to determine whether the event would
undermine the licensing objective of
public nuisance and serve a counter
notice stating the reasons for that
decision
or
to allow the licensable activities to go
ahead as stated in the application and
the notice and that's the end of the
report thank you
thank you stephen
now the members of the suck meeting may
ask questions of stephen
and
anybody like to ask some questions
no i don't see any hands
no okay then
i'll i will move on
so
before you move on i couldn't get to the
participants in in time
if you got a question
thank you um chairman um to stephen um
what is there
a maximum number of people allowed on
this particular event
i can confirm on the application it has
stated the maximum will be 100 people to
be attending
as per the
application thank you
thank you
okay any any more questions i do imagine
if you can't get the hand you can press
alt and y and that will put a hand up as
well
no okay so i will move on so
shivan if you'd like to state the uh
case of the authority
okay um thank you um 43 tillingham way
is located in the cul-de-sac location
and it's surrounded sorry chair just to
interject do you just want to double
check that none of the other um
represent like the other parties had any
questions
the applicant or the responsible
authority
tony or or and anita have any questions
of simon no
okay
sorry
she won no problem um so yes um 43
tillingham way is located in a
cul-de-sac location and surrounded by
residential noise sensitive properties
um nearby to 43 tillingham way is
sheltered accommodation chignol house
and it consists of 44 flats and it
provides accommodation to people over
the age of 60 or over the age of 55 if
their room seat of certain benefits i.e
disability living allowance
the application made is for a 21st
birthday consisting of a marquee in the
back garden of the property finishing at
midnight
uh environmental health are of the
opinion that the complaints and that
complaints of noise nuisance are likely
and that if the event were to take place
it will undermine the licensing
objective for the prevention of public
nuisance a marquee in a residential
garden provides no sound attenuation the
materials a marquee is made up of means
that it's very very close to being
acoustically transparent
a dj will be providing the music
and music up is made up of
different frequencies and low frequency
or bass and travels very easily through
windows and walls without being absorbed
and are more likely to be heard
this um is a 21st birthday party it is
anticipated that the type genre of music
is likely to be bassier um you'll also
have the potential of people singing
along to some of their favorite songs
um
considerations should also be given to
the ambient sound level reduces at night
and therefore background noise levels
will be significantly quieter at the
time of the event taking place
um consideration should also be given
that on conclusion of the event you have
a hundred people disbursing into a
cul-de-sac location or people will
continue to linger chatting into the
early hours of the morning
therefore environmental health of the
opinion that this type of event would be
more suited to an indoor location or a
location where there are no noise
sensitive properties
face
is finished yeah
thank you thank you any members have any
questions of
siobhan siobhan
council stanley
your mute counselor stanley
asset thank you um
thank you uh chairman um just how close
are the properties that you mentioned in
the in the way of the home and that sort
of thing to the
relevant uh place of the party
um i haven't got exact measurements but
the um property is located in the middle
of a residential built up area and is
surrounded by properties on all four
sides
uh is is is the pro is the
the homes that you're talking about are
they within
uh that area that we're talking are they
sort of in close proximity that's what
i'm trying to get at yeah
the area that will yeah so um the area
as you say is a built-up residential
housing estate so the properties are in
close proximity to each other say the
actual property is at the bottom of a
cul-de-sac so it's got properties on
either side as properties to the rear um
and um when you look on google maps
there is a footpath and then and there's
sheltered accommodation
on the other side of that footpath and
then say that sheltered accommodation
provides 44 flats for elderly people
so it's your question cancer stanley
thank you thank you chairman thank you
okay so gooding you got any questions
have the
uh
applicants got any questions
the council officer
no
okay
i will move on to the uh
could the applicants like to provide
put their submission across
please
hi
um so as i mentioned um
we have been running our um events
business for 21 years
and over this time we have grown and
have recently included the sale of
alcohol where we gained our personal
licenses in september 2017.
in all the time that we have traded we
have never received a call from the
abatement officer for sound
we are a respectful company not just of
our clients but for the environment in
which we reside and over the years have
gained contracts with many local venues
including the rayleigh club the holiday
inns in both south end and basildon the
west cliff hotel halfway house saxon
hall in fact we even do the sound and
av for rochford council for your
business breakfasts
our hotels use us
as they know that we control not just
the noise level but also the frequency
we do roll off the base
because this is the
this is the cause of the majority of
sound travel
there also know
they also know that we will turn the
music off at 12 o'clock
not just for their license but for the
comfort of the customers of the hotels
in which they they are also and staying
recently we've been working with
rayleigh club
as they have had some noise issues with
local neighbours and on the
investigation by the rayleigh club they
have now restricted anybody else that
can play there to eternity events
or indeed they have to be supervised by
us
as for all jobs of this nature we will
keep the noise to a respectful level
within 80 decibels i believe that is
we will roll back the base to restrict
the sound travel the marquee is lined to
absorb some of the sound and we will
record all the sound levels with a
decibel reader which we use in in lots
of our venues
at this time of year it is cold weather
and so most people will have windows and
doors closed
and with the recent coronavirus pandemic
i think the people are a little more
tolerant for people having parties at
home
we have
undertaken a number of jobs in marquis
in gardens over the years and since our
approval with our mobile bar many are
outside of the
of rochford jurisdiction but one of the
most
similar setup that i can draw your
attention to would be in 69 cheapside
east
just before the pandemic on the 1st of
february 2020 which ran without any
concerns or complaints
i've asked tony to join mate because he
is will be overseeing the sound aspects
of this event as he has done for all of
the events over the last 21 years and
has all the technical knowledge
regarding sound
and i've asked miss mrs neville and her
daughter alex whose party it is so that
they can
share any specifics around their
neighbors but patricia informs me that
she has not only contacted her
neighbours but invited them to the party
to celebrate their daughter's 21st
birthday
i hope that you can see that although we
like to party we do do this in a
respectful manner which is how we have
been in business for all this time
we
have and would not want to jeopardize
this for the sake of one party so we
respectfully ask you to approve our
application for a temporary event notice
at 43 tillingham weight on the 4th of
december
thank you anita um is any witnesses do
you like like to speak or
anything would
alexandra
yes
you've muted yourself again
oh i would just also like to add
actually although i put 100 on the um
temporary event notice that was just to
allow for any fluctuations in numbers
but actually i i believe alex and
patricia would be able to tell you that
i think it is actually um less than a
hundred i just wanted to be on the safe
side and again with the timings i always
set up a little bit earlier just to
account for anybody wanting to start to
drink a little earlier but actually i
don't believe the party is due to start
until 7 30 and the guest numbers are
lower and patricia and alex would be
able to fill you in on those exact
numbers
thank you
patricia and alex if you've got your
hand up you'd like to meet yourselves
yes hello um yes there is actually going
to be about 80 people attending
um i have um although our
our close neighbors are actually
attending the party they have also i've
got three written statements here
from our three closest neighbors just
saying that they don't have any problem
at all with the issue of having a
one-off party
so i don't know whether you need me to
send these into you i'm quite happy to
do that so you can see them
um but again it it's part i mean my
question as well is
if we didn't have eternity events doing
this party we would have the party
at home anyway and it would be in the
garden and we would have a marquee up so
if we was using our own music
then you're still going to be faced with
the same issue
we wouldn't have to we wouldn't have had
to have gone to the council to do that
okay thank you this is our own private
property
thank you
anything else anybody else wish to add
on that
okay
um the members got any questions they'd
like to ask
questions
jim
council good in your mute
this is to uh alex and um
what is the parking like
around your way is it is it good parking
would it be could you see it causing a
problem the parking
is not going to be a problem sorry
it won't be a problem um we've got a
drive that houses five cars anyway my
daughter actually lives in cheap side
west
where we're going to be moving two of
the cars around there off of our drive
um and there is also further down the
road there is a wall
situated on the right hand side
and that can house parking with no
restrictions at all so
it's it's not an issue for us
right and the slamming of doors when
people leave expector you don't see that
being
an issue
there
there will be an awful lot of people
that will be taking taxes in that anyway
plus i'm i've i've got about 30
members of my family come in anyway and
they're not you know
they're the same age as me they're not
going to make a load of noise when
they're leaving yeah
no that's fair enough thank you
thank you
fish jim
first councilor stanley
thank you chairman um
although you we've um looked at the
parking situation and and noted that
the the the some of the residents some
of the participants will be coming in
taxes 80 people could land up with you
could end up with 60 cars um being at
the at the at the event
um and there isn't adequate parking
around there but nevertheless um and
also of the
late-night slamming of doors um have you
got a marshall
that is responsible for the parking of
the vehicles and
people leaving
um
i would request that you would have a
martial i would suspect you would have a
marshall for that
also something to tony
the
80 decibels um
can you give
give any indication as to
what the pitch is
with 80 decibels at 9 o'clock at night
when
the atmosphere is very very quiet there
is no noise from traffic or anything
like that to to dull the noise down um
can you give a demonstration of what
that is please
um you say
the pitch i'm not quite sure what you
mean by the pitch what you mean the
level 80 decibels
yes yes what the what the 80 decibels is
in relation to what we would normally
hear from a radio okay so when when um
when people sometimes sing at the rainy
club without any actually amplified
music they they quite often hit 80
decibels so 80 decibels is a low level i
mean the level that's set at the rainy
club is 90 decibels but i will be going
off property with the
monitor every hour and recording the
decibel level um something that we
didn't um put into the application
either that i must add is this is
actually a 70s and 80s themed party so
all the music is going to be 70s and 80s
it's not a 21st birthday rave where it's
going to be
r b music and very bass driven music
it's actually a 70s and 80s theme party
everyone's going in fancy dress so the
music is going to be
of those of that genre so um it's not a
21st birthday rave where it's all garage
and jungle music which is very bass
driven um it is actually a 70s and 80s
themed party so you know i think that
needs to be taken into consideration
because it's a very
different type of music to what the 21st
waves are
thank you thank you tony um
anyone just come back please gentlemen
um
yes in relation to the parking will
there be a uh monitor on the parking
uh
[Music]
you mean a marshall council martial a
monitor whatever you like to call him um
that's that can that can
ease the parking around that area or or
several of them i don't know what's you
know because there could be an awful lot
of vehicles and people that need to get
to their premises or need to get away
from their premises and that includes
ambulance and and
fire engine should that should that
happen and should that occur it's no
good putting the cars in the road when
emergency vehicles can't get down the
road to get to the emergencies so
and i do understand tony that you have
had
uh venues
not
other than the one in cheap side
um but most of your venues are in larger
places so that wouldn't come into effect
but this is a cul-de-sac and the venue
although it be
as you turn around and say
um a
70s and 80s uh theme um it's still
nevertheless it's in a confined area and
i just wonder if we are if you have got
the right uh
you know the right things going on in
that
with your with your um
uh um person that you're dealing with
yeah
okay
thank you counselor stanley who'd like
to answer that
um well i could answer and say that i
will put one of my members of staff on
the parking when people are turning up
i'll have someone out the front and we
one of the things we would never do is
block someone's drive or indeed block
access for emergency vehicles as we said
in our statement we are a responsible
company and we don't we're not going to
just do the party without any
consideration to other people in the
area and that's not how we operate um
you know um and going back to the cheap
side east um
uh party we did that is also a
cul-de-sac
um so and that was the same and actually
you know we've over the summer we've
done probably 30 30 or so different
marquee jobs every one of those has had
a dj but not all of them are about
alcohol or they've supplied their own
alcohol so i haven't needed a need for
license and many of those have been in
culvy sacks and very small confined
areas um
and again you know to my knowledge there
hasn't been any complaints
um you know i
know alcohol policy for me and all of my
staff when i'm working so when we're
working we are completely on top of
what's going on um and keeping in
control of things uh you know we and we
act in a responsible way not only to to
the people whose party is but if there's
any neighbours that have got any slight
concerns we will address them
thank you very much tony is that um
okay councillor stanley
yes thank you for that thank you thank
you
um
siobhan you've got your hand up for a
question
uh yeah i just wanted to clarify um
obviously in regards to
um the applicant um when we received
complaints of noise we would write to
the occupiers of the premise not
necessarily the applicant so unless
you're going back to your applicant
after the event
you might be unaware of complaints being
received in regards to noise for events
that have taken place
in respect of obviously temporary events
because if we would take any kind of
formal action it's normally against the
occupier of the premises and not
necessarily the applicant so you might
not always be aware that we're in
receipt of complaints about that
particular event or premises
um also just to clarify as well um you
referred to the railey club and their
decibel level of being 90 and db um
considering that's an indoor event 90 db
and you're looking to provide 80 db
outside in
a marquee that has no sound attenuation
whatsoever and there are also a
conditions attached to their premise
license and for that particular premises
that plays 90 db in regards to having
windows and doors closed at all times um
and they're not allowed outside after a
certain time and so i just wanted to
clarify that in regards to some
comparison in regards to what the noise
levels are and also you referred to your
sound level meter and could you clarify
as to when your um sound limiter was
last calibrated and is it in accordance
with the manufacturer's um
um guidelines in regards to um
calibration well it's brand new this is
a brand new meter which we've just had a
lot of new ones delivered so i guess it
comes calibrated but you can you can
calibrate it so we could calibrate it
the day before
so you can self calibrate it on and set
it
so it's a simple so you just calibrate
the meter
okay
sorry can you just confirm when you
purchased your meter
um
about
six weeks ago six to eight weeks ago
yeah yeah
um
i had in my mind and from your first
question sorry and i i i need a reminder
on to what it was
i think was it to do with the lining of
the monkey
no because the marquis
your marquee is going to be fully lined
it's going to be fully um um lined which
it does absorb a lot of sound
and i think because there's a air bond
between the
lining and the actual um market marky as
doug said that air bond also gives you
some um
protection
thank you
uh siobhan said okay
okay um
oh i'm sorry
she was saying about the not knowing
about the um
uh complaints and stuff actually the the
people at um
69 cheap side in fact have become
friends and um actually i'm sure they
would have told us had there been any of
concerns so
we've actually
socialized with them since then
okay thank you uh alexander and you've
got your hand up if you want to add
something to the question that
shiron asked
yes i just wanted to ask siobhan a
question um how do people stand when
they're in their own private property
um and they do have parties and dj's
when you're not aware of it
well obviously we receive complaints to
the council don't get complaints
well if we don't get complaints there's
nothing to investigate but the whole
purpose of um this process of going
through the license subcommittee is that
obviously it's been brought to our
attention that's 21st birthday it's been
held outside and we're of the opinion
that complaints are likely based on our
experience of events that have taken
across the district and obviously and
the locality of your premises in regards
to being in a built-up area
and as you say as a local authority when
we receive complaints and noise we have
a duty to investigate those
okay
do you actually need me then to send you
these statements from the neighbors
because we've got the three neighbours
statements we've got the house next door
to one of the neighbours that's actually
currently empty because it's been sold
we've got another neighbour across the
way that's going to be away from next
wednesday
so alexander can't i just stop you don't
ask
solicitors do
they necessarily chris
thank you chair um i think
usually you would want any kind of
written evidence that kind of thing
before the hearing and it is i think
within your
discretion chair if you want to accept
that or if you would rather and perhaps
this would be the best option is to kind
of
you know give appropriate way after the
hearing to what's been said
um orally to that evidence rather than
kind of being sent through anything now
but like i said if you feel you need it
as members then you can
but um it may be better kind of at this
stage of the hearing to to kind of you
know after we can kind of discuss how
much weight you want to give to those
representations
i'm happy to give weight after hearing
when we discuss this
thank you members are happy with that
yes okay
um
counselor stanley if we can make this
the last one if nobody else has got
anything important anything yeah just uh
just a quickie uh
chairman um
does the
sound
volume at 80 decibels
um can that be lowered
um as is not
um
it's not necessary really to have
quite loud music i'm sure that the
company alone will make the music or
enjoy the the party as they would do
whether it was
lowered uh to a better degree to uh help
the
um
area that it's being held in
um the marquee in itself will have an
opening
for people to come and go so you'll have
one quarter of the marquee open
and the sand will be
coming from that area
so even though you've got what you say
as a
buffer zone in the marquee you've got
one quarter of it open for the sound to
come out
unless you enclose it completely and and
you wouldn't get 80 people in a marquee
i don't suppose for for
doing what they're doing
unless you're in a field of course but
we're not in a field at the time so can
the decibels be lowered please
um
tony if you'd like to answer that
hello there yes absolutely the decibels
can be lowered um you know we've got
full control over the volume um and we
will be knowing it now we're also
heating the marquee so the door there is
there will not be one call to the
marquee open the marquee actually has um
a door in it which basically operates on
a zip and once the people are in the
party the marquee will be will be heated
so we will not be keeping the door open
um for that reason because it's going to
be quite cold on the 4th of december so
we've got heating going into the marquee
so the door will be kept kept down
obviously people will need to go in and
out of the door to go to the lavatory um
but i can i can lower the music to to
any level you know it can be it can be
set at any level 80 80 decibels is is a
fairly low level
um but it can be lowered you know it can
be low you know we're only going to use
very small speakers in the excuse me in
the market we're not taking we're not
taking what's called base box speakers
and then tops it's not going to be a big
disco setup it's going to be we use
what's called a 10 inch speaker which
gives a very tight controlled sound and
not the deep bass that goes below 100
hertz it's below 100 hertz that causes
the noise pollution so we can anybody
this this system has settings in it so
we can actually roll the speakers off
and tell them not to deliver
below 100 hertz to the actual
loudspeaker it's called a dsp setting
and that's what we do in a lot of our
venues especially hotels where you've
got people sleeping upstairs
so the people in the party get to enjoy
the music
but it's a volume that it doesn't
interfere with other people and you
haven't got those big deep bass notes so
and the marquee is big enough for 80
people it's um
it's an eight meter by six meter marquee
going in plus an extension so it's
effectively a ten meter by six meter
marquee which is is adequate for 80
people because we're not having any
tables and chairs so it's going to be a
dance floor and a bar area so
you know all 80 people will be inside
the marquee
okay thank you tony
is there any any more questions at all
i can't see anybody with any more
questions so right then so now we come
to
closing statements
uh classes have two minutes
each for closing statements so
stephen you've got a closing statement
uh nothing from myself thank you
thank you siobhan
sorry um just to reiterate obviously
this is the marquee in a back garden and
built up residential area
it's a tent that cannot be conditioned
so the option of lowering the db level
might be an informal agreement but it's
not something that can be enforced
because no conditions can be attached to
the ten and we're still of the opinion
that this type of event in this locality
is likely to give rise to complaints of
noise nuisance and will undermine the
licensing objective of public nuisance
thank you
um who wants to give the closing
statement from the applicants
um i would just like to reiterate that
we are a respectful company that will do
all we can to minimise the disruption to
the uh local residents and that we will
um
i forgot i was going to say
all that we can to minimise minimize the
disruption
um
and for this one-off party that it's not
as if it happens on a regular basis it
is to celebrate um alex's 21st birthday
with her family and friends
can i just add that obviously as being
in the
in entertainment's industry you can
imagine that our business has been
absolutely decimated you know decimated
to zero during covered um and we're just
getting back on our feet so
while we do fully respect your concerns
we you know we
i think you know there should be some
consideration taken into the fact that
we are
working in a
responsible manner and we will take into
consideration any neighbors have got any
concerns but you know we would like to
be able to function as a business and
and uh you know and and celebrate alex's
21st birthday party but thank you thank
you very much
right then thank you everybody for
participating the committee will now
adjourn to consider the case
we will turn
we will return um shortly i don't know
how long so don't know how long we're
gonna be
talking about this
um
and
the uh
announce the decision
the decision can all be sent
decision will be sent to you in writing
if you say you don't have to wait but
you're welcome to wait if you'd like to
it's on you we'll get in touch to invite
you back when we've made a decision
okay
super thank you so so how do we wait so
what was um i think stunned um because
they seem to have a
part two is it just that i
ring back in again at 3 30.
so chairman if i if i may um
we
i'm assuming that mr greener has got
contact details for you um so as soon as
we're ready to start that part two
hearing which will be roughly around
about half three it might be might be
sooner might be slight later depending
on how long it takes to deliberate we
will contact you to let you know that
we're restarting okay